[Music]
hi everybody how you doing today you're
hitting the end of the conference it's
like the tired part but we're going to
be okay so I'm here to talk to you about
API design for JavaScript libraries and
how you can do some sharing so I will
say up on the screen are my two kids and
the oldest one Dalton really really
likes to tell you that sharing is caring
when he wants to eat the food you have
on your dinner plate so Who am I umm I
really think that you need know nothing
other than semicolons tabs all the code
in the slides is semicolons tabs in all
seriousness I work for Microsoft I am a
crisis management engineer so if you're
hosted on Azure and your things are not
working I am the person who is on the
phone being like everyone wake up I am a
maintainer of moment.js there are two of
us here today I don't know some of you
saw maps talk earlier but I'm a
maintainer of Amadeus in addition I am a
the J's Foundation's representative to
tc39 so I'm on the committee that makes
ACMA script and I represent the J's
Foundation which is an awesome
organization that supports open source
projects in the JavaScript ecosystem I
could give a whole talk about the Jazz
foundation but I'll simply tell you that
if you have made an open source commit
to a JavaScript project we represent you
so if you would like representation at
tc39 Leo ball turned myself are your
representation as an open source
committer and on that note I am
the champion of the date rework proposal
that was talked about earlier so if
you're interested in what's happening in
JavaScript date I'm working on that but
today that is not what we're talking
about today what we're talking about is
libraries is anybody here besides me a
library author okay all right
I'm going to bring up some libraries and
if it's one of yours and I got it wrong
you shout real loud you got that library
wrong Maggie so what is a library um
there are a lot of definitions for the
word library but what I'm going to go
with is a library is a bit of code
that's useful when it's packaged up and
distributed to other people this could
be internal or external so there are
tons of external libraries that we know
about libraries like lodash jQuery Q
moments immutable and requests those are
all libraries right I think probably
everybody in the room knows almost every
one of those all right um internally
there's a tendency to make internal
libraries I know at Microsoft we have
like millions of internal libraries for
the purposes of logging and analytics oh
my gosh I add internal libraries to
everything for that for the purpose of
this talk I do want to define what is
not a library I am going to come out on
a limb and I'm going to say things like
Express or angular or webpack are not
libraries for the purposes of this talk
instead what Express or angular would be
would be a framework they're a framework
they do a whole lot more than provide
some useful code they tell you how you
should code webpack on the other hand
would be a tool to full tool suite so
I'm not going to consider those things
libraries one other thing I want to
mention about this talk is that I'm
going to get out examples from some of
the libraries I have listed at the top
and we might think of those libraries as
like lame like jakers from 2007 guys but
the bottom line is these libraries have
survived a really long time
so we're really into the new hotness in
JavaScript but for the purposes of this
talk I have stuck to libraries that we
are all still NPM installing several
years later because longevity is good
call me lame it's okay I can live with
it so here's what we think having a
libraries like anybody have kids and
yeah so that's good these kids behave
like this all the time like happy and
playing all right so here's a how many
libraries actually because anybody maybe
have this toy besides me this is a toy
only a grandparent would give you
there's two kids there's some buttons
and there's some whipped cream this is
what having a library is like out in the
open source space like that looks really
fun and then BOOM except in the other
space it actually looks like this
Tim Wood awesome guy author moment.js
was like I'm going to share and I'm
going to care and here we are five years
later with 2,400 to clothes issues and
176 open that's what having a library is
like and your best defense against that
is making it well so what makes a
library good small size
I never want to hear about it again
great code your users don't use your
code they're never going to look at it
encourages functional programming
practices big right now isn't it oh wait
wait wait
this is JavaScript the amazing nodejs
web pack beveled mocha try fans and
sauce Istanbul toolchain that I spent 12
weeks assembling that made my library
good guys ease of use ease of use nobody
wants to learn the library
they won't those two thousand four
hundred odd github issues 50% of them
are I did not read your documentation
it's okay to make it simple you don't
have to get into fancy patterns your
users are just going to go let's partial
application so I'm going to break this
out into four areas one invocation how
do I invoke my library how do I actually
call it to configuration this is a huge
part of any library like doesn't do what
I want it to do unless I change this
configuration this way three defaults
what should the default behaviour in my
library be and finally errors which with
the advent of nodejs and server-side
JavaScript are no easy thing to deal
with
so invocation basically for any library
there's two kind of simple ways to
invoke it one is static invocation right
you just call a function so here we have
two great libraries that I think
everyone here is probably touched
requests from node and this is a static
invocation I want to get google.com and
I get a call back it's just static or
good old 27 million NPM downloads a
month low - who here hasn't used it I'm
asking for filters and I get back a
filtered list awesome
um static invocation is a great pattern
I would not shy away from it for logging
libraries this is the way to go it's
easy you just say dot log dot error it's
easy for people to figure out they don't
have to think too hard about what's
going on so this is actually my go-to if
I want to write a simple library it has
a drawback though here's a low - without
using any of the chaining or functional
features if I want to get the some of
some odd numbers doubled we're going
down like this almost looks like a call
back Christmas tree but it's not it's
just low - all right so when you start
getting into this kind of trap with your
library then you're probably going to
move to doing something like a factory
function now many libraries have done
really well with the factory function up
here I have cue everybody's use servers
use queue right oh yeah
it returns promises doesn't it queue
fundamentally the library it makes
promises and then you can do what you
will with those promises jQuery good old
ubiquitous jQuery makes jQuery objects
can learn that when they first started
coding ten years ago and moment my
library by the way I am going to shred
moment in my examples I will tell you of
my pain but moment again is a factory
library you invoke moment and you get
back a moment object and these kinds of
things allow for some really really good
patterns to happen a factory function is
what's going to allow you to go into a
chaining API or at least it's one very
good way to do that so here we can see
queue again we're doing s call which is
going to give us a promise back and then
fundamentally we can chain on another
promise and chain on another promise
because we just keep getting promises
all the way down so this is a super
helpful way to invoke a library to have
it give an object back and then have
that give an object back there are some
problems with chaining but on the whole
it's worked really well for a lot of
people here's moment the reason people
love women is because it does a changing
API Here I am adding three days to the
curve
time and then I'm going to the start of
that day and then I'm going to a year
ago gosh knows why I'd want to do that
but believe me people have and it reads
really easy I'm reading left to right
I'm not questioning like where is this
invocation in the world I'm just
cruising along jQuery again like for all
that we like to riff on jQuery for the
bad programming practices man does this
get our work done I still bring in
jQuery if I have a mostly static like
asp.net MVC web page why not so the next
set of patterns that I'd like to look at
our configuration patterns
now almost every library in the world is
going to need some form of configuration
and it can get pretty difficult for
people to figure out how to do so we'll
take a quick look at moment this is a
moment like circa 2012 and it was great
um you had a date string and you could
either pass it into the moment
constructor and at the moment
constructor deal with it or you could
specify a format to make sure that the
constructor got the right thing this was
beautiful this was easy moment 2017
constructor here you can construct with
an array you can construct a moment from
another moment object that will give you
a copy you can construct a moment from a
date I guess that makes sense you can do
a date string with a format in the
English language or any other language
you can use strict mode which will force
you to match the pattern that you're
supplying you could combine language in
strict mode Oh multiple formats maybe
you're expecting four or five formats
I'm going to throw an array in there and
I still need to support language and
strict mode whoa like that was intense
by the way having this kind of
overloaded constructor where your
constructor is expecting like a billion
options I think some moment uses you
have six modules and I think to actually
like parse out this construct
it happens in about ten files that are
all about 100 lines of code each just to
parse apart this madness is like type
checking and then what does this
actually mean this is not great I'm
going to get some credit here to my
colleagues on the echo 402 committee
they've been putting together the new
internationalization API has anybody
used this and you know yeah the Intel
API okay so the expo 402 standard said
how are we going to do configuration
because localization takes a heck of a
lot of configuration and they came up
with this really simple paradigm and for
all that it isn't fancy I love it I
think is really going to serve
javascript users over time and it's this
I'm going to create a new date time
format here I must know the locale for
the format the locale is required right
so I put the required parameter here and
then everything else I need to know I
put an options object now this is used
the world over in a million libraries
and it's used because it works I'm
easily specifying hour minute second in
time zone name format without having a
mess in my constructor without having to
change defaults to the global object
like none of that is happening
so options objects it seems simple it
seems almost stupid for me to say but
they're going to get you a long way and
cleaning up constructors like I showed
you with moment the other thing that
they do and again good old jQuery you
were beautiful you really were
is there really you have some flexible
business logic if you actually go into
options object land then say you want
the user to be able to define a behavior
in the library you're going to be able
to do that with something like this here
we have jquery ajax requests still great
after all these years and if i want to
handle the 404 i can pass a custom
function and if i want to handle 500 i
can pass a different custom function
this is beautiful this is easy for the
user
so basically when it comes to
configuration du required parameters at
the beginning of your constructor
and then tie the options object to the
end this is going to be the easiest way
for anybody to invoke your library
defaults now defaults are a fascinating
topic and they're difficult to get right
let's look at this this is a plain HTTP
request with the built in node jsap is I
assume a lot of people here have done
this the plain no library HTTP request
and some interesting stuff is going on
what I want to do here is I want to get
the moment github repo so I'm going to
Tim our would slash moment okay great
is you might get requests and a few
things get crazy here I actually feel
like continuous update stream can cat
response body but what I want to call it
is this
I get redirect 301 permanently and
that's absolutely true because Tim moves
the moment repo to the moment org like
years ago but now because I got a
redirect I'm going to have to like start
this whole process again I'm going to
have to go look for the redirect link
that I got that's kind of a pain request
anybody here a request user right
there's a great library it does a lot of
good stuff for us but a big one is it's
going to automatically follow a redirect
so here when I kick off my request for
Tim our would moment I actually get back
like the repository I wanted with the
data about it it just automatically
followed the redirect now what this is
is best by default when was the last
time that you got a redirect link and
didn't want to follow it right I'm sure
it has happened and I'm sure you can
configure request to not redirect but
like seriously this is like 95% of the
time 99% of the time you're going to
follow the redirect so if there's an
obvious right best answer like that's
like well over 90% case then do it right
but here's the flipside I'm going to go
back to moment nothing like
the library that I love so much here I
have moments and I'm passing in this
date string let's point out 10:25 and I
get out 17:25 why so here's what's
actually going on with moment time is
complicated and when I passed in 10:25
to the base moment constructor I get
back 1725 because it's converting it to
local prime minus 5 here and then I came
to Berlin time right if in fact I had
one at UTC I would use the UTC
constructor if I had wanted to stay in
minus 5 I would use parcels own if I had
wanted a different time zone for
instance New York then I would use the
time zone constructor
there's no good default here like
honestly are any of those like the thing
that you do all the time or any of those
in 95 percent case no and like this
single API flaw has caused more support
issues in moment.js than any other thing
by about three orders of magnitude like
people like wisely this is a date I
thought it was going to be and all we
really had to do with this instead of
having that default just moment paren
constructor if we had made people choose
if we had made them say moment dot local
they would have gone Oh
local time and it would have saved us I
don't know how many hours the next time
we Rev a major version for me to
deprecate the default moment constructor
and put in local will be all the 30
minutes of work and it is happening
we're not living like this anymore get
to update all the docs and then you get
to update your code
so default only when there's a best
answer there are several likely
behaviors don't work yourself into the
trap of entering support requests on all
of them so the last thing I want to talk
about is errors so errors at one time in
JavaScript we were liking happy fun land
I where on the path I will just go heirs
to the browser and it'll be really great
and then we'll hit f12 and we'll see
that and then this happens
this is directly out of the nodejs docks
any use of the javascript throw
mechanism will raise an exception that
must be handled using try catch or the
node process where it will exit
immediately so who's had this happen oh
yeah okay so as library authors we were
like you're going to use it on a server
and then the errors going to happen and
we're going to crash the server Oh God
and for a long time we people got this
idea that like library should never
throw errors never throw errors in a
library you will kill things but that's
difficult too so I actually like any
good software engineer I went to Twitter
and I was like does not give any
official guidance about this error thing
several years in and it like exploded
into a massive Twitter conversation that
lasted like four hours and the only
feedback I really got from node is that
miles cares a lot about errors he wanted
me to tell you so miles cares a lot
about errors but the general consensus
on the thread can be summed up as throw
an obvious developer error so let's
break that one down here's moment doing
actually a pretty good job at a thing
this is a date and it's probably user
input and user input is always
potentially junk right so we don't want
to every time a user enters a date if
that data isn't in the format that we
want
not exploding nodes servers so instead
what happens is that we very politely
take your input and we say oh you have
tried to format this invalid date and
then maybe your one user with a bad
input sees invalidate but at least we
haven't taken out your node process so
this is good bad user input doesn't
crash but then we have this other thing
going on you can either get on moment to
get the hours date part moment get hours
and this looks great it gets us back
thirteen that must be sometime in the
early afternoon that I ran this but this
is weird I misspelled hours I put in a
nurse and I get back the moment object I
would completely expect to get a moment
object from that method invocation we
should have found at the end of the day
this wouldn't be deployed out onto a
server in production this is a developer
time error and it's one that's
potentially very difficult to find
you'll go digging through your code and
you like where is it why do I see JSON
where I should see a string what the
heck and you'll get all the way down to
our library and you like those people so
let's look at an example if this
actually being really done well so here
is this is immutable people use
immutable from Facebook sure good
library
what immutable does is it makes
immutable collections so here we're
going to make a map and anytime we
change this map it's going to give us a
new map and this is this library doing
it very well we're making a map abc123
and we set B and the first map still has
two in the second map has 50 so that's
what it does okay but it does something
awesome here when I try to make a map of
the number one which is like impossible
because like how do you map the number
one it actually tells me hey developer
we expected an array or an interval
object could you hand that over
this is good when it comes to errors if
it's going to happen at runtime if it's
about the parts of user input then
you're going to want to try to suppress
as best you can
for nodejs but if you can tell like the
dev fat-fingered something help them out
and undo the fat finger
so in conclusion just make stuff easy to
use don't get fancy don't spend a lot of
time thinking about what are the
functional paradigms I can use here and
how beautiful can my code be and what
tool chain can I have at the end of the
day all the libraries that have shown
you have lived for years not because of
their amazing tool change their small
size or anything other than the fact
that people pick them up and were able
to use them quickly so put your
investment as a library author whether
internal or external right there for
invocation static or factory what a mime
is going to work out for you chaining
may really enhance your problem domain
options objects for configuration
everybody knows them and they really do
clean things up defaults careful careful
when there is an obvious right answer
then pick that to be your default but
don't pick an arbitrary default do not
do it and finally throw for those
obvious developer errors those will make
it so that your users aren't sitting
there complaining about how you are a
horrible person they couldn't find this
really mysterious bug in their code and
after that just share get out on github
get you know inter source through your
company get people contributing to your
library internally and be friendly and
be open to new ideas alright well thanks
everybody I love questions so
once in my fantastic moments as Louis
please